-Oh, I love my next guest.
He is a multiple Latin
Grammy-winning superstar
who you can see
in the giant new film "F9,"
which is in theaters tomorrow.
Please welcome Ozuna!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ah! That's my man! Yo!
Ah! So good to see you, bud!
-How are you, Jimmy?
How are you?
-I'm doing good, buddy.
It's so great to see you again.
You know, you've been on
the show a bunch of times now,
and every time, you crush it,
so thank you.
But the first time
you were on our show --
I don't know
if you remember this --
This was is in --
-Yes.
-This was in Puerto Rico.
-In Puerto Rico
with Jose Feliciano.
-Jose Feliciano, that's right!
You remember!
Yeah, that was the biggest --
-I remember.
-Was that the --
Have you worked with him before?
-That's the first time
I've seen Jose Feliciano.
-Yeah, he's really funny.
He loves jokes
and fooling around.
-Yeah, but the first time
you see --
Yo, you see Jose Feliciano,
you think, like,
he's serious people, you know?
It's the music, and the --
you know, the career he have,
it's a serious, but --
-Yeah.
-He's a funny guy.
The day with Jose Feliciano
is a funny day, for real.
-Ozuna, you're about
to start live shows again.
-You know, I'm ready to open
and to do the first show
in Aguascalientes in Mexico.
-You are? Yeah. I mean --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to see it.
If you get a chance --
Talk about an amazing
performer -- Ozuna always.
You know, I was checking out, I
was doing some research on you.
On the Internet, your videos,
nine of your videos are
over one billion on YouTube.
Billion by the way, not million.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Billion.
Including "Taki Taki,"
which is over two billion.
And I tried to research this.
And maybe I'm wrong,
but does it mean anything?
What does "taki taki" mean?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I don't know
what's "taki taki."
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you.
Well, what is it?
-I don't know what it is.
[ Laughter ]
They call me -- They call me
and send me the beats.
That's when I got
the show in Mexico.
I remember, and he say,
"Yo, I need this song for today.
I need something.
I need the first 50 seconds,
45 seconds.
And I want to do songs
featuring around the world."
And I got one hour.
I got show, so let's do it hot.
I got to call my engineer
and say, "Yo, let's do it."
And when I practiced
with the melody of the song,
and I say "taki taki."
[ Singing in Spanish ]
But that's the -- you know,
the melody got the instrumental.
So, I sent the next night back
and he called me one week --
the next one week, he say to me,
"Yo, I got the best feature
with Cardi B.
But I got one surprise for you.
Come to the video."
It's the next month.
I go to the video,
and I see Selena Gomez.
So I say, "Yo, you got
the best surprise for me,"
because I didn't know
Selena Gomez was in this at all.
-Yeah, and you're like,
"I don't even care if taki taki
doesn't mean anything.
This is going to be a hit!"
-I don't know
what's "taki taki."
Everybody says,
"Yo, what is 'taki taki?'"
I don't know
what is "taki taki."
-Is there anyone that you
haven't collaborated with yet
that you want to?
-Right now for me, the dream,
I want to collab with Rihanna.
I got, in my package, I got
a song, so for me it's a dream
because I respect so much,
Rihanna,
so I want to do
something with her.
-Alright. That's alright.
That's coming up next.
I want to talk about "F9,"
by the way.
Not only are you
just global superstar,
we know you from your music,
but your acting is
fantastic as well.
And then, you're in "F9."
It's going to be the biggest
movie of the year by far.
We can't even show a clip,
by the way,
because you're kind of a spoiler
in the movie.
And so -- For real.
[ Laughter ]
So we're not even really
allowed to talk about
what your scene is,
but it's cool.
[ Laughter ]
And that's all I can say.
But how did you get involved?
Did you go through Vin Diesel?
That's usually what I would do.
[ Laughter ]
-It really is a dream, because
the first time call me,
yeah, you go to --
"We got something, 'Fast 9.'"
I say, "Yo, that's real?"
I want to go to "Fast 9"
because I'm calling for
a Latin movie.
Not go off to, you know,
American movie
or around the world.
Doing a movie is the same as
going to university.
Real, real, real.
Doing a movie is the same as
going to a university.
So it's day by day,
and the people.
Day by day and the people.
And the tips, they give me,
Vin Diesel for the movie,
like it's a huge show.
It's a dream, in this movie,
and it's an opportunity for
my career and for the brand.
-I've read so many articles
about you.
And you're very humble and
funny, but also I think I read,
like, twice that you said,
"I want to retire at 35."
And I think you said
you want to go to space,
or you want to go to
the moon or something.
-Yeah. That's my dream.
[ Laughter ]
I want to be like Elon Musk,
give me, like, some --
a little space in the moon,
so I'll go up with him
and get my life there
with my family.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, Elon, Elon,
give him -- give Ozuna a call.
We always love seeing you, bud.
Congrats on everything,
the tour and the movie, "F9."
Ozuna!
"F9" is in theaters tomorrow!
That's my man.
Come back whenever. We love you.